ever what was your oh no are you are you
what are you Italian and Irish half half
Italian and Irish Siciliano me too
let's see the difference is I look I
look Irish yeah and I've got the body in
the [ __ ] of an Italian I don't know you
look like like a little tiny Swedish boy
you are like a little Swedish boy yeah
yeah it may be little tiny Swedish boy
I'm a Brian a Calum yeah you the other
Brian a Calum that's an Irish girl and I
and I know horrible Swedish is an Irish
guy this is clearly Irish man whoa do
yes that's Irish in Jamaican no this is
Irish guy so to make this is higher okay
welcome to Ireland no that's no welcome
to the island of Ireland man the very
land come over get some fish and chips
and fruit and salad no see that falafel
this is Ireland salad couscous on the
island of Ireland no that sounds so
Jamaican is not even close did you make
in Jamaican accent you want to join IA
I'm Jamaican I'm a big black Jamaican
guy everyone knows I'm Jamaican best
Jamaican super Australian you're so bad
with dialects you don't know I don't I
studied in college dude I did
dialectical research that was one of my
focuses what was your what was your
major in college journalism and English
journaling journalism major English
focus and I had a dialectic subset I did
two and a half years of learning
dialects around the world came but name
a place and I can do it Maori Maori you
want Maori yeah okay
welcome to D so no body iya iya puddin
or mommy me hold you on daughter sheep
and you didn't understand the language
because I was also doing some okay okay
Russian Russian Russians probably
probably one of my favorites to be
honest with you Russians easy Russian
goes I don't you want to eat you want to
eat fish or you do you want to go and
your separate ways because dinner is
Miette okay now I have to uh that's well
now looks I don't take this the wrong
way but that does sound a little
it's French well you you're going you
want me to kick out here some more bacon
I hear these and don't make it okay
don't make it can I hear it
Japanese easy Japanese is probably one
of my favorite ones to do alright I have
to get prepped for it ready yeah you're
mine right who I dunno you don't know
how to do this with me I wanna dance on
your lap and maybe shake I'm opposed to
push the [ __ ] I have to stop here
because it's so good did you just get
transform like you were back in Tokyo
Japan I'm so [ __ ] Spanish you guys are
so wrong maybe I am I'm telling you
you're wrong I went to a [ __ ] school
for dialectical research okay maybe
Saturday we walked Central Park all day
and I argued with them how boys get
sucked off at night then and he begged
to differ I should talk to Brian why Jay
goes Jay goes that was back in the day
now it's clean I walk at night no I said
to the rambles what that's why I told
him it's dick-suck central walking
around knows that I mean I walked
through there and suck his dick right
now to make a point it's sown in the end
I mean it that way but I'm just saying
maybe here you meet him argue that the
entire Central Park walk I'm like dude
I'm telling you to take sector he's like
not anymore they cleaned it up no no no
he usually only cleaned it up oh he
didn't no don't clean up when grown men
at 1:00 in the morning wanna bang it's
they they go home around Jay said Jay
goes I'm gonna walk here at night just
to prove to you guys the way you prove
me a get through the rambles I know yeah
I told you this story I walk through it
at one morning in Central Park and I got
that it was just dudes like that I've
never been a Central Park it's really
nice oh yeah what are you talking about
a gas car that's where the Ryan lives
and performs we got to go to Central
Park it was cool there yeah my mother
wants me to fly in now there's a family
reunion now when you're on TV I don't
want to say this it's not I'm not saying
anything about might I'm not sure my
family but there tends to be this idea
that because you're on TV it would be
nice for you to be a family reunion
maybe because it's something to talk
about maybe I don't know maybe you're
the center my mother my
was proud well you basically the pig
with the Apple in hizmet well my
mother's proud of me so maybe my mother
wants to her cousins and stuff to see
that her son made what did I don't know
that's not my mother's style but I'm
just saying getting out can I can I jump
your management tell your mom yeah cuz
cuz let me let me just say what my mom
wants to mom Callen she says I'll fly at
Planet redeye at 10:30 at night after
you shot all day correct you have an
idea with the shin so fly fly and then
you go all the way to New York yeah in
the morning premiere at about 6:00 in
the morning you take the red-eye yeah I
take the red-eye and then and then hang
out on Saturday and then come back
Sunday morn now he can that can I tell
what I think mom Macallan 75 grand
that's what it would cost for me to do
that but he's my son I know I'm sorry I
could pay CA a thing I'm sorry you try
to shoo bribe me she goes I'll pay your
ticket Wow stuff yeah 50 grand you know
Carolyn suppose he's on SETI's me little
late today but can I interrupt you for a
second please Dubrow brian is such a
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude we texted him and I five or six
times to make sure that this is
confirmed and I said I'm so happy to be
back with you guys sure enough he's not
here he texts to Leah and itís no you
text Alina this morning were still on
supposed to be me you too Leon Callen I
was checked with the guests in the
morning it's called boom refresh
national you're a pro I'm pro right guys
dude Santino D'Elia tomorrow
yep I'm like all right are you man I
haven't heard anything about I talked to
Chris everyday Chris hasn't mentioned it
so I'm like ah Brian got this no it
takes you guys nothing nothing I texted
you back you didn't Chris goes what
today today today is the day you gotta
keep me a little bit more abreast
so when Callen does come in if he does
come by in a sock am I gonna knock him
the [ __ ] out stupid when I knock him out
do you imagine Brian can fight can Brian
fight he can he's so handsome
well he can is suppose for his age who
would you put him against well who what
other 67 year old would you put him
against I mean Rogen's only 50 but real
Rogan would row and 12th is Hannah him
who's somebody that he'd have a good
competition fighting like a legit fight
yeah who would be a good fight cuz you
know Delia Delia I think would murder
Lee would [ __ ] murder younger he got
a lot of real she's big you gotta go I
like you and cow it's [ __ ] fight
we'd be a good fight he's older than me
by a little hot but we would be a good
fight stick it to him I think Brian and
I have the same kind of like we have the
same kind of anger like I'm I yeah we
have the same kind of like you know
Brian's really nice and sweet but inside
deep down he's dark dark dark
some would say the darker the darkest
you know I don't get a dark vibe from
you I got it in there dude Fiona real
atomically I got run out my house the
house that I bought there was a house
old house that definitely flatlined and
obviously built my crib above it but the
house there I'm starting my neighbors
they said that they the shirt owners
fried by the get in place they said
before that my house was built the
person who lived there was an old lady
who had polio
she used to have brackets on her on her
legs and would just stand in the window
and stare at the Rockies and then the
people who like the coast lady
well no not at the time then she'd
passed away and the daughter from my
neighbors would take care of her then
she passed away house got leveled
[ __ ] Scrooge McDuck comes in right
someone else buys the house I buy it
from them but they used to asked the
neighbors cuz they'd go out of town so I
asked my neighbors did you see anyone in
the window they'd be like yeah we
thought you guys were oh my god lady I
know but I was like was she friendly she
was like yeah McElveen she's probably
jaylen man yeah I don't get scared yeah
now did I go to the bathroom this
morning past my closet thought I saw
something screwed back to my [ __ ] bed
yeah I did okay and my girls say like
lights turn on randomly and [ __ ] my
grandmother I come from the most cynical
family of doesn't believe in any of that
stuff like where my even heaven like my
grandmother was gonna die she knew and
she goes and said well you know in the
afterlife somebody saw them in my
grandmother one if there is an afterlife
can start a podcast yeah guess who did
you I I'd hate to be shitty here Andrew
did you give him the okay to start a
podcast
did you I didn't either I did it's weird
yeah he's I could have swore we run this
town
yeah and by telling me podcast and if we
want to turn people against your podcast
hmm you mean I gotta do is float a
couple rumors though is the bun right
here is that the button yeah let me tell
you a couple of reasons why you
shouldn't push that button hold on all
right I'm gonna listen first of all
always been a fan and a friend to you
shop you know that say no one
hey nobody got are you good at
negotiating
second of all you won't even come to me
you've always been hyper pay the piper
I'll pay the piper yeah we'll see Mel I
know you run the block I'll come give
you a little how you do yeah yeah I'm do
what I'm supposed to do and maybe one
hour because I'll win you wanna make Shh
I don't need to talk talk talk with the
wind blow whose town this is runs to
[ __ ] okay okay so I'm not ignorant I'm
arrogant but I'm not ignorant hey stop
take your finger off the button I just
did man all right we're back it's good
to be honest with you baby yeah they
[ __ ] talk you into anything
I know man I know I can salesman hey
I'll sell you something what's your
least favorite food on earth I mean for
me I can't stand tongue Steve beef
tongue beef tongue is disgust I hate all
those I could never eat olives I'm gonna
pitch both you at the exact same time
cuz I've been selling beef tongue
dollars for about 26 years no one to
town someone I was eight
you're a purveyor of olives and tongue
well sometimes I do stuffed olives with
tongue beef tongue we do stuff no way I
can eat that let me tell you why why is
it that we marinate it for four and a
half hours yeah in virgin vert virgin
put pazoozas
origin pose Jesus Wow delicious it's
good for your health it's good for your
eyes
yeah regrows your bones in your body
yeah we've been testing it for about six
or seven months now everybody we've
tested is it put muscle on you probably
not absolutely does you know Chris
D'Elia you know that guy is the comedian
version of me yeah
but bigger with real muscles like real
honest man you like never used to look
like that oh wow nope it's from your
beef tongue from our beef your stuff our
beef beef tongue olives double beef
tongue olives why are you pushing this
from female beef beef juice peafowl of
beef beef cow tongue beef it's cow con
they're called beefy Kong
olives now is Elliman most Koreans come
home with cow [ __ ]
and that would be in Hong Kong cow
tongue [ __ ] its carrion what do we call
it [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] on top there it
sounds I'm kind of in and can I tell you
a whole jar this thing five bucks yeah I
got so much money five bucks so I just
think give it a whirl what do you think
vinyl dancers yeah jars two or three let
me start with ten and we'll go from
there
all right sound all right photographer
was arrested at a wedding she was a
wedding photographer but she had sex was
one of the guests and then peed on a
tree outside of she why would you arrest
a good save in her body was 26 year old
and here's no there's no problem here's
her she's a bikini model - yes why did
they arrest her she's because she does
she peed on the tree yeah
Jesus come on she's outstanding I love
that sex outside I can't tell where that
is
they'll take Malibu dude hos love Malibu
well I mean first of all good on you I
have nothing but good things to say and
I got arrested yeah I can't believe how
far she could use a full rack of ribs
but whatever I'm very happy with the
whole situation I appreciate her talent
as a photographer she ate her giving
back that's what I appreciate and you
know and she so she peed on a tree lucky
tree dude you lost weight I'm so glad
about the subcommittee no it's weird
we need new pictures for find the kid oh
you know what we really you know we are
Christmas Card
I would love to get out there and eat
and have her shoot yeah we do the beach
but whenever going takes place in studio
in studio and on Saturday night yeah
nice - I mean your place gross yeah love
drinks yeah that's it it's cold outside
baby it's cold outside
yeah anyway well this is also what she
said y'all's family will be dead by
Christmas y'all's daughters are dead she
told the cops
so she was super drunk [ __ ] my dad is
gonna find out about this y'all are
[ __ ] dead
d e a D daddy
she was daddy dead she was trunking you
know but why does she might be who's our
dad
I don't know let's find her daddy I feel
bad for her she also mixed alcohol with
medication this is embarrassing
like this is embarrassing to a human
being like she had we've all been there
I've never done in one way or another
I'm saying we've all been done
embarrassing things like [ __ ] and peed
on a tree what are we talking about
I [ __ ] outside and peed on trees yeah
I have and that's what I've never been
like y'all are dead
well maybe daddy's gonna kill all you
maybe she was drunk as [ __ ] and was
taken even drunk I've never said looks
like anti-anxiety medication
this is [ __ ] terrible to say what her
dad's now does leave her alone just do
that I mean Oh back up please I wanna
you know what you know what you know
what she needs she needs you to laugh
and you tell me laughs Brian and Brenda
that's what I'm seen eat some relax and
my guys go for massages right come to us
and I'd like to be I'd like to welcome
her back with with the open door we'd
like to pay for your what right is
you pay the hog Rafi you pick the hotel
nice photo shoot some pictures will be
taken on my phone I'm a fan some on
yours fan all the way around full
supporter you can bring your daddy bring
your dad bring your daddy you know you
have two daddies waits outside uh uh
wait you don't have to bring a daddy
because daddies are waiting waiting
waiting when you see my back rippling I
pull myself up like a champ like a champ
2:30 time span
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gift it's a gift
it's a gift